E aí
[Música]
e há mais de dois anos a 3 anos comecei
a perceber a forma como a desinformação
pode mudar as coisas muito práticas e a
forma como viver eu tenho que confessar
que quando comecei a investigar este
mundo das fake News Eu não fazia a mais
pequena ideia do seu poder imaginava que
as campanhas de propaganda baseadas em
mentiras ou as teorias da conspiração
restaurante também cada dia mais
correntes fossem apenas uma angústia
longínquo uma nova versão da Guerra Fria
dívida nos servidores de longínquos de
Washington em músculos geridas por
Espiões estudos eu não preciso dizer que
não é assim ao contrário do que eu
pensava a mentira uma eficaz arma de
propaganda também aqui em Portugal
Irineu Vocês desconfiados que sempre foi
mas nunca foi assim acredita aquilo que
eu chamo de informação à falta de melhor
termo que seja mais curto ou mais exato
é um problema muito mais sério nosso
templo que era digamos assim 100 anos
quando uma mentira precisava de ser
impressa no folheto para ser credível ou
passadas de boca em boca por milhões de
bocas até a causar danos
e as campanhas de manipulação da
informação que é base todas as nossas
convicções e crenças nascem com mas em
uma vilã com a invenção de uma mentira
essa mentira criada com o propósito que
levarmos a nos acreditar que é verdade é
tudo normal como sempre foi deste mundo
é muito o que mudou então não foi a ver
as mentiras assim colar foi um método de
levar ao nosso conhecimento e mediar e
ao conhecimento imediato de milhões de
pessoas foi Além disso a forma como
Essas mentiras passaram a chegar ao
nosso conhecimento transmitidas por
pessoas em quem confiamos aos pais os
nossos anjos e nos irmãos os amigos
porque aquele like mentiras tantas que
nunca nos bastarão equipas de check-in
para a desmontar a todas e depois a quem
criar contas falsas nas redes sociais
temos sites de ganho contas de e-mail
falsas programas de computador para
replicar mentiras A novidade é que essa
ordem de milhões de
O que é o limite fogo que todos os dias
me pedem amizade no Facebook com nomes
bem mais do que nem todos apresentam
naquelas Poços tiras de bem o uniforme
militar todos os dias em o Twitter com
links alguns minutos minutos ou tem
canais no YouTube a função desses votos
em encher o nosso espaço público
mentiras pensadas para nos manipular as
redes sociais sou o sítio onde a maioria
de nós e as editoras no mundo se informe
e ele aqui esse processo de nos informar
de nos manipular tomar forma a repetição
de uma mentira torna mais credível
garantem os psicólogos sociais que estão
a falar agora nossa forma de validar
crenças o objetivo final destas
campanhas de manipulação é convencer
muita gente De que a verdade é outra eu
não preciso dar exemplos mas lembrem-se
sempre hoje quando a cada vez mais
informação ao dispor do maior número de
pessoas a cada vez mais pessoas que
acreditam que a Terra é plana por
exemplo não me lançarei com outros
exemplos menos benignos como depois tipo
das vacinas antigo ouvido ou o
negacionismo da
e nenhum daquelas mais mirabolantes
fantasias obscuras do grupo e o anônimo
também tem adeptos em Portugal por isso
eu comecei para vos dizer que nós não
aprendemos ainda o suficiente para parar
Este é um dos mais sérios problemas do
nosso tempo eu queria que seria o tempo
escolhemos um inimigo principal da
história e da minha opinião esse inimigo
são as contas falsas os perfis
fabricados nos blogs e se a manipulação
da identidade e com ela do nosso debate
coletivo que devemos reagir antes de
mais mas as empresas dominantes do mundo
online Facebook o Google ajudar o das
maiores exemplo não estão não estão ou
não querem criar regras que garantam a
identidade digital dos utilizadores eu
quero que elas fazem mal se me permitem
esta crítica a identidade digital não
imitem nada a liberdade de expressão ou
Anonimato pode ser essencial para quem
vive em regimes repressivos nada impede
que uma empresa digital cria
identificação de uma conta por cada
pessoa identificada pelos meus netos que
nos permitem ter uma herpes no banco um
perfil no supermercado para as
a regra deveria ser simples uma pessoa
um perfil depois disso perfil tem o nome
real onde o seu dormem mal Cunha isso é
computador se conseguimos limitar a
proliferação destes botes e contas
falsas e as fontes bem informadas pelos
garantem que as contas falsas podem ser
até cinquenta por cento dos 2,7 mil
milhões de utilizadores da maior delas
Já começamos a impedir a fábrica de
mentiras de funcionar podemos então
olhar quando negócio que alimenta quando
comecei a investir café comigo em
Portugal encontrei negócios muito
rentáveis em páginas feitas no Canadá se
dedicam a espalhar de informação em
português e que só em publicidade
saturavam mais 10 mil dobrar mensagem a
publicidade direcionada que se alimenta
da grande coleção de dados privados nós
do amo as empresas online sem termos as
vezes consciência de que estamos a fazer
essa tem que ser regulada de uma forma
rigorosa como é regulado por exemplo a
publicidade da TVI na imprensa e então
por fim de podermos chegar a parte mais
complexa que todo este sistema de
informação que vai para
e os algoritmos esses complexos
mecanismos para ver o que é que nós
gostamos de ver para nos servir nos
vicia tem que ser te mais transparentes
debatidos escrutinados porque não
decidimos como comunidade que redes
sociais devem disponibilizar mais um
algoritmo de funcionamento para que nós
obtemos pelo que mais nos Convém se a
maioria das pessoas não têm problemas o
atual e gosta de ver este algoritmo
tecido o que deve ser feito nada muda
mas tem alguns de nós não querem receber
discurso do ódio vídeos de apanhados
Publicidade devem poder optar por isso
todos como comunidade precisamos ter
este debate com urgência mas ação mais
decisiva acabamos também a cada um de
nós individualmente o êxito a
desinformação depende sempre de nós
somos pessoas concretas e da capacidade
que temos de Resistir desconfiado sendo
cépticos sabendo informar se a
desinformação é o nosso problema somos
nós temos de combater da forma como
gerimos a nossa intimidade online e
procuramos informação para formar
convicção
e dependentes de uma comunidade a que
chamamos e banho de virtual
ah é verdade o jornalismo hoje vive uma
crise eo ameaça e um paradoxo nunca
tivemos tanta informação disponível e
nunca foi tão fácil de encontrar
documentos explicações e factos dos
extremos mais bem informados os estudos
demonstram que não é que a informação é
apenas mais um banho que temos ao nosso
dispor para consumir online a informação
não pode competir com o nosso tempo com
as mesmas armas que o divertimento
entretenimento usam porém as redes
sociais são negócio publicitário não
hierarquizam importância social das
coisas damos aquilo que acho que ele vai
interessar e o jornalismo que precisamos
é muitas vezes chato aplicativo longo
demais para lermos no telemóvel enquanto
o semáforo está vermelho e surrealismo
demora tempo tem regras e nem sempre se
torna viral por isso hoje infelizmente
muitas redações desistiram e o fazer
preferem apostar no clix para tentar com
isso competir com a nossa atenção que é
limitada existir do jornalismo não pode
ser a opção dos cidadãos que querem
estar informado pelo contrário temos de
saberes e dos jornais das revistas das
rádios
é um regresso aquele rei o tema que é
tornar interessante que a razão esse a
nossa exigência não foram vida temos que
seguir todas as outras formas que
pudermos porque nós queremos viver
livros numa sociedade informada basta
que fazemos uma pergunta muito simples
de cada vez que navegamos é redes
sociais ou encontramos um link em
qualquer que nos interpelam uma pesquisa
do Google essa pergunta é a pergunta que
eu vos deixo como mais importante de
travão que podemos cada um de nós usar
para parar a desinformação devo ou não
devo partilhar esta história
E aí
[Música]